What is mankind’s plan B for when poor old
Earth has ceased to be.
Gone to meet its maker, rung down the curtain
and joined the choir invisible?
What happens when Earth is an ex-planet.
Well, then it’s time to hop over the fence
and set up camp in our neighbour’s garden,
even if it’s a red and desolate wasteland.
Just over 78 million kilometres away on average,
Mars isn’t quite our closest neighbour,
that’s normally Venus, depending on its
position in its orbit.
But Mars is definitely the best candidate
to sustain life.
And we’re not talking about just going and
living in a caravan full of baked beans and
oxygen, we’re talking about a full civilisation,
out walking on the surface of the red planet.
So is this really possible?
Could we actually make Mars into a place where
humanity could survive?
Could we breathe?
Could we grow food?
Are there any good bars?
Today we look at the steps we would need to
take to become the Martians of the future.
Now getting to Mars is something of a challenge
and it could take anywhere between 150 to
300 days, depending on space traffic.
But this timeframe is perfectly manageable,
although a bit boring.
The real issue is getting the huge volume
of stuff we’d need to colonise from the
surface of Earth out into space and then over
to Mars.
Right now, it costs around $25,000 to get
just 1 kilogramme into orbit around earth.
And although the money is obviously an issue,
think of all the resources, time and dedication
it takes to launch just one rocket into space,
never mind a continuous fleet of spaceships
travelling to Mars with supplies.
Think how much effort it was to build the
International Space Station, and that’s
only 400 tonnes – that would barely carry
the toothpaste and peanut butter needed by
the Mars colonists.
One proposed idea is to build a space elevator.
It’s a surprisingly simple concept; you
just need a cable attached to the Earth that
extends out beyond the distance of a geo-synchronous
orbit.
By that I mean the orbital distance where
a satellite rotates at the same speed as the
Earth, so it stays in exactly the same position
out in space as the start of the elevator,
back on Earth.
The cable would have a counterweight at the
end.
The counterweight would swing around, like
a tetherball, and the centrifugal force would
be enough to counteract Earth’s gravity,
which would mainly be acting on the lower
end of the cable, having much less influence
on the further away parts and the counterweight
itself.
This would keep the cable taught and now you
could run an elevator up and down it, using
much less propulsion than you’d need for
a rocket.
Some estimates say that it would bring the
cost of putting 1kg of supplies into orbit
down from $25,000 to under $250.
The obvious technical difficulty is building
a cable that would need to be around 100,000
km long.
But with the development of materials such
as carbon nanotubes, it’s beginning to look
more possible.
The cable cars, called climbers, would probably
use rollers to pull themselves up using friction
but there’s a limit to how fast they could
go up the cable, partly because of the strength
of the material but also because as you get
higher, you are picking up a huge horizontal
speed, caused by the rotation of the earth.
This is called the Coriolis force.
You’d also need to power the climber.
The journey would probably take 5 days, so
you’d either need a powerful nuclear reactor
or, the most likely solution, you could beam
the energy up to the climber using a laser
– meaning less weight being carried on the
vehicle itself, and more room for snacks.
So if the elevator works, and all we need
to do to get material into space is listen
to a few days of awful elevator music, the
next step is sending everything over to Mars.
This is where the moon could come in very
useful.
The moon would never be able to have an atmosphere,
so it’s hopeless as a colonisation prospect,
but its lack of atmosphere is actually a huge
advantage because it means there is no friction.
The great science fiction writer Arthur C
Clarke discusses this in his non-fiction collection
Voices From The Sky.
It’s worth pointing out that he also popularised
the idea of the Space Elevator in his 1979
novel The Fountains of Paradise.
One idea that Clarke put forward is that you
could build a giant space gun that would fire
spacecraft down a track on the moon’s surface,
and fling them out into space.
The craft would only need small propulsion
rockets to make adjustments for its entry
into Mars.
This space gun wouldn’t be possible on Earth
because the friction of the atmosphere would
create too much heat, and you’d probably
kill about a million pigeons every journey,
as well as everyone on board.
But on the moon, with a track just 30km long,
you could get the acceleration you need and
remain under the 10G that astronauts currently
experience when they leave earth.
If you weren’t sending people, you could
use a much shorter track.
The technology that we currently use for maglev
trains would work extremely well for this,
using a magnetic field to both float the vehicle
above the track, and to pull it forward.
This is why Elon Musk and others are looking
into creating vacuum train tunnels for terrestrial
transport; no air means no friction.
Speaking of Elon Musk, the amazing achievements
of Space X and the privatisation of space
travel is probably what will make this whole
colonisation project a reality.
We’re still going to need rockets, at the
very least to build and maintain space stations.
But when Falcon 9 landed on an automated drone
ship this April, after sending supplies on
to the ISS, it showed that we can finally
start reusing rockets, potentially turning
a $60 million trip, into just $600,000 for
fuel and maintenance.
To get started on Mars, we’d need some pre-made
living spaces.
They’d probably initially be something like
those put forward by the Mars One project
– a small series of contained compartments,
which you could link up.
Therefore, it would be easy to just shut one
part off when you have a problem.
And when it comes to keeping the astronauts
alive, well Mars has some very important features.
Thanks to the work of our first Martian, the
hard working Curiosity rover, we now know
that there are all of the basic elements we
need in the ground and the atmosphere, so
we can create breathable air from what is
already there.
There is ice in the soil that could be used
both as drinking water and to produce oxygen.
There’s nitrogen in the atmosphere so we
could make our favourite cocktail of earth-style
air, more or less.
So that’s water and air covered, but what
about food?
Future colonisation attempts on Mars, such
as Mars One, plan to send a boatload, well
a spaceship load, full of fresh food to the
planet in advance so it will be waiting for
the colonists when the arrive.
But when that food runs out…
well lets just say things get pretty grim.
The Martians will live mostly on a diet of
algae and insects.
Food will be produced hydroponically using
artificial lighting.
Martian soil will be used to grow plants and
carbon dioxide will be provided from the Martian
atmosphere.
The nutrients for the plants will come from
recycling human waste.
Lovely.
And if we move beyond just the basics of keeping
people alive, what about things like communication?
Even though you moved millions of miles away,
your grandma is still going to expect a call
at Christmas to explain why you aren’t married
yet and why didn’t you get a real job rather
than all this fancy space nonsense.
Depending on the relative positions of Earth
and Mars, a message travelling at the speed
of light can take between 3 and 22 minutes
to go from one planet to the other.
That means phone calls are out but texting
and internet messaging would be fine, so one
day the solar system will be cluttered with
a constant stream of emojis.
So, how’s Mars?
Desert icon, skull and crossbones, sad face.
One other idea that Arthur C Clarke put forward
in Voices From The Sky is that you could use
lasers to beam much higher volumes of data
across space, if you make use of the moon
once again.
Lasers would be distorted by Earth’s atmosphere
but you could use the moon as a relay station,
so messages could be sent that short distance
to the Moon by radio waves and then converted
to the more powerful laser form, and vice
versa.
This means large data dumps of technical information
would be much easier and you wouldn’t need
to limit the coloniser’s communications.
So the Martian folks would be able to send
all the selfies they want from Mars back to
Earth; Yeah we get it, you guys are holding
a Mars bar on Mars, very funny.
But now we come to the really important question;
can we make the whole planet liveable?
Humans are actually pretty limited in terms
of the environment we can survive in.
It’s not just the chemistry of the air but
also the temperature and the pressure that
are important.
Of course we could spend all our time in spacesuits
but it wouldn’t really be a normal life
and it would make Martian Next Top Model a
whole lot more repetitive.
Besides, no one wants to spend all day in
a suit.
The atmosphere on Mars is mainly carbon dioxide
and it’s at a far lower pressure than we
have on Earth.
At our sea level, the pressure is about 100
kilopascals.
To make life easier, we normally refer to
this as one atmosphere (101325 Pa).
The lowest pressure us puny humans can breathe
in, unaided, is about 0.4 atmospheres.
Anything under 0.2 would require us to wear
a suit.
Mars is all the way down at 0.01 atmospheres.
You really don’t want to be out in that.
In 1966, a technician was testing a spacesuit
in a vacuum chamber.
The suit failed and there was a rapid loss
of pressure.
The man quickly fell unconscious but he recalls
that the last sensation he had, before he
passed out, was feeling the saliva boiling
off his tongue; so without a spacesuit on
Mars you would rapidly boil alive before exploding
dramatically.
To increase the pressure of the atmosphere,
we would face some major issues, one of the
biggest being that Mars lacks Earth’s powerful
magnetic field, called the magnetosphere.
The Sun creates a solar wind; a stream of
matter, such as protons, electrons and alpha
particles, that are sent out in all directions.
The part of the Earth facing the Sun, the
day side, is shielded from this particle breeze
by the magnetosphere and deflects much of
it away, keeping us safe.
Some does enter through the poles and this
is how you get the Aurora, otherwise known
as the Northern or Southern Lights.
We believe Earth has this magnetic field because
of its liquid outer core.
The moving molten metal deep inside the Earth
acts like a dynamo, just like how the spinning
metal of a bicycle wheel can create an electric
field and power a light bulb.
Mars once had this too eventually the planet’s
core cooled down and now its core is totally
solid, so its magnetic field was lost.
Without the protection of a magnetosphere,
the solar wind blows away much more of the
atmosphere, thinning it out.
We have not yet come up with a good solution
to this problem.
What we do have are a variety of ways that
we could at least create the atmosphere once
again and raise the temperature of the planet’s
surface.
The south pole of Mars holds a lot of frozen
carbon dioxide.
If we could heat the surface a few degrees,
the CO2 would be released into the atmosphere
and would then act a greenhouse gas, like
it does in a problematic way here on Earth.
This would then warm the planet and you could
use simple life forms, like Phytoplankton,
to convert some of that carbon dioxide into
oxygen.
You could then slowly introduce more complicated
organisms and carefully build the eco system.
As our knowledge of genetic engineering grows,
we will probably be able to alter the organisms
to work better in each stage of the changing
environment.
We’ll also be able to make 6 armed monkeys,
orange dolphins and dangerously fat mice,
just because we can and it’s funny.
So how would we give the planet that initial
kick of energy to release all the CO2 and
create the desired greenhouse effect?
One idea put forward is to just bounce more
sunlight up to the pole with a series of giant
mirrors.
We could use a substance called PET (polyethylene
terephthalate) as you can stretch it very
thin while maintaining a reflective surface.
It would be pretty slow though and I’m not
sure Mars would want to be staring at its
awful red face in the mirror every day.
A quicker method, although much more difficult,
would be to go asteroid hunting.
If we could find a few massive asteroids,
rich in ammonia since this is also an excellent
greenhouse gas, and smack them into Mars,
then it would really speed up the whole process.
But it would be a bit more complicated than
just sticking some cheese on a big stick and
hoping the asteroids are lured across the
solar system.
We’d need to play a gigantic game of pool,
bouncing smaller asteroids into bigger ones
to put them on the path we want.
But all of these challenges are just going
to make us push all that bit harder to find
a solution.
And every year, new technologies are emerging
and new ideas and approaches come from across
the globe.
Of course, we still haven’t thought about
the question of Martian society.
Who knows what new religions and cults will
spring up on the red planet.
And will it be a separate nation and have
a whole new set of laws of its own?
Will they have a Pappa Johns, we’re all
dying to know, but we’ll just have to wait
and see what the next few decades bring.